je crois qu'il vaut éviter les
expressions du genre savourer ou être
jovial parce qu'il ya un chiffre qui est
un très bon chiffre
un mois le mois précédent il était de
moins bonne qualité était même à
linverse a d'ailleurs été saluée si je
puis dire par l'ensemble des
commentateurs sur le thème terrible
affreux épouvantable aujourd'hui je
n'emploierai pas des termes inverses
calme en cours un chiffre qui est de
même l'an dernier ce chiffre parce que
moi je connais bien ces mécanismes de
chiffres mensuels du chômage
j'ai été ministre du travail jean
connaît à la fois la pertinence parce
que ça indique des choses et en même
temps je reconnais la volatilité des
actions quand je regarde une chose je
regarde une seule chose que s'est il
passé au cours des derniers mois
que s'est il passé par exemple depuis le
début de cette année est-ce que
trimestre par trimestre ne prenons pas
mois par mois parce que c'est un six
mois par mois
enfin je devrais dire c'est ainsi mois
par mois mais est ce que au cours de ces
trois derniers trimestres est ce que le
chômage a baissé
c'est le troisième trimestre consécutif
avec les trois derniers mois où le
chômage baisse en france s'est défait je
ne dis pas qu'il faut s'en réjouir ou
qu'il faut s'en satisfaire
définitivement mais les faits c'est que
le chômage a baissé ou titre des
chiffres de pôle emploi depuis le début
de cette année est ce que ça va se
poursuivre en ce moment là ce sont juste
pour que les gens aient le charentais
que ça reste pour 90 mille chômeurs de
moins depuis le début d'année
on est dans le rejoint cela rejoint un
autre type de chiffres
ce qu'ont toujours les gens s'ils
perdent là dedans qui est le chiffre
international le chiffre des
comparaisons internationales
c'est le chiffre qui était à vie par
l'insee avec des règles dites du bureau
international du travail
et ces chiffres là qui ont été
d'ailleurs cité dans un débat qui avait
lieu juste avant cette émission sont des
chiffres qui indiquent que depuis un an
le chômage baisse en france le
pourcentage de chômeurs par rapport à la
population active ne cesse de baisser
depuis alors ça pour le dire simplement
et le chômage baisse clairement en
france depuis un an et vos derniers
chiffres qui viennent d'arriver confirme
cette évolution à la baisse du cac
baisse est ce que c'est l'inversion de
la courbe annoncé
si je devais reprendre cette expression
qui maintenant est totalement
dévaloriser puisqu'elle a été utilisée
réutiliser au commentaire critique et la
vérité c'est que quand le chômage baisse
depuis un an ça doit s'appeler une
courbe inversée du chômage mais laissons
cela de côté
je pense que pour les français c'est
presque plus compréhensible ainsi et
c'est comme ça je l'espère que pour ceux
qui retrouvent de l'emploi ils le vivent
le chômage baisse en france depuis un an
c'est clair net et précis et toutes les
statistiques vont dans le même temps le
chiffre